tjc it is national french friday
and mcdonald's of course is celebrating
by giving one customer
a lifetime supply ted florindo is that
you
to enter fry fans i need to share their
appreciation by tweeting at mickey d's
before
july 20th using the hashtag
mymcdonaldsfan contest
and include their home state meanwhile
today anyone can get a free medium fry
through the mcdonald's app by opting in
for awards really all right you know of
course
we had to celebrate national french fry
day with the game
yes naturally all right
all right ted just walked in as you can
see what's up and
he had to get we have to you know get
him to be part of this because
he's so much fun we have three different
fry options for them
three okay different fast food
restaurants
we have mcdonald's del taco
and burger king okay all right we'll
have their blindfolds on although i
don't really trust those blindfolds
i don't trust them i don't trust them
either at all i don't really trust those
to guess which fry is from which fast
food restaurants
yeah left to right okay sure okay left
right okay right okay
go wait where's my left right here
okay oh crazy this is like your first
fries in like years
a long time okay so then we were on the
sec the middle one right
how does it taste jc those are delicious
this is amazing
all right all right from heaven was okay
all right what do you think the left one
is we've got about a minute left
middle one eat fast because i i eat
french fries all the time
that's the only thing is mcdonald's okay
okay now i'm on the middle one are you
still eating the left one
jake oh my god
mcdonald's okay are you guys ready you
guys ready your guesses
yeah okay let's see um i need water we
have the little papers right in front
don't we have any water
we never work right in front so you can
wait can we take our blindfolds off yeah
did you try all three of them yeah i did
all right i am a french fry all right
guru you are a friend he's a french
fried group all right we gotta move on
guys come on
okay okay let's do it okay i'm going
what
do we say i said mcdonald's burger king
del taco
no i'm going to del taco burger king
mcdonald's
where are we going what is an italian
producer
mcdonald's delicious burger king can i
get it right shut
up i got it right you are such a
we'll be right back